So what do these concept of depth and
defocus imply here?
So here basically,
now I'm showing you this whole image.
Because of the fact that things
that are at different distances and
the fact that you have optics, and
the sensor itself, any image I take
will have this artifact, right?
These objects are a little bit further
away, they are out of focus and
this frame here,
this part obviously that's in focus.
So, only a few specific planes,
depending on the camera and
the aperture and
stuff like that would be in focus.
So this is in essence is the artifact
of a traditional camera system.
We will always have scenes
at different depths.
All of them will have different focus.
And of course, the question comes up
is can you actually compute the depth
just from knowing this focus planes
that are different in this image.
So depth from defocus
basically is attempts to infer
depth by analyzing the local scale.
That is, how is, much is the dif,
difference in the frame itself or
difference in the focus itself
in local parts of the image, and
use that to compute a defocus blur.
And if I actually can figure out
the defocus blur, I can actually kind of
claim knowing the lens that I have,
how far a certain object is.
That's what basically you
saw in the last example.
The more I moved the object,
I got a different blur out of it.
Now, if I could actually create
a relationship between this,
I could actually start computing depth.
We saw examples of that when we talked
about computing depth from images in
the lecture on stereo.
But the bottom line is,
this is an extremely difficult and
ill-posed problem.
because we actually have a tougher time
of actually figuring out the calibration
that will allow us to figure out how
much defocus blur exists in different
parts of the image, that will allow
us to then actually compute how far
those objects are in that image.